القول ان سكان العاصمه الى الاوكرانيه كيف
قضوا ليلى هادئه مقارنه بالايام السابقه و
الليله التي قبلها اين
استهدفتكييف باكثر من 35 طائره مسيره حسب
عمده المدينه بتاع الكلاشينكو هذه
الطائرات المسيره استهدفت 9 محطات لتوليد
الكهرباء واعطالتها على اخرها مما اسفر
على بقاء اكثر من 50% من سكاني كيف بدون
تيار كهربائي لمده تجاوزت ال 10 ساعات ده
هنا الاداره العسكريه الاوكرانيه قالت انا
منظومه الدفاع الجوي اسقط 19 طائرات مسيره
همم كانت هنا في الغطاء او الغلاف الجوي
الاوكراني وفي علاقه قديم المجاوره همم
ليله امس تتنقلنا الى احدى هذه المحطات
التي تم استهدافها وسطها العاصمه كيف
موجوده بالقرب من احد الاحياء السكنيه
والتجاريه ووقفنا على حجم الرعب الكبير
الذي عاشته العائلات هناك عائلات قضت ليله
دخلتها خارج المنازل في على المحطات في
محطات المترو في ملاج سباق بائع ده انطلاق
صافيرات الانذار على الساعه الثانيه صباحا
الى غايه السادسه صباحا في اشاره الى وجود
غارات في اكيف وفي اشاره الى بدء منظومه
الدفاع الجوي كل الاوكرانيون هنا همم
تجددت تجددت وتعقدت معاناته وماساتهم جراء
القصف المتكرر وقرر وجراءه الانقطاع
المتكرر ايضا لتيار الكهربائي وللماء اصبح
من الصعب جدا هنا العثور على مولدات
كهربائيه بسبب الطلب الكبير عليها من قبل
اصحاب المحلات التجاريه من اجل الحفاظ على
تجارتهم ومن قبل سكان من اجل ضمان
من التدفئه اعيننا الاوكرانيين ليله امس
واليوم كانت موجهه نحو العاصمه
البيلاروسيه اين التقى الرئيس الروسي
البيلاروسيا اليكسانجه
الاداره العسكريه من تشدد العمليات
العسكريه الميدانيه انطلاقا من الحدود
البيلاروسيا مطلع العام القادم